we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard
because that goal
will serve to organize and measure the
best
of our energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we're willing to
accept
one we are unwilling to postpone
and one we intend to win and the others
too
many years ago the great british
explorer george mallory
who was to die
on mount everest was asked why did he
want to climb it
he said because it is there
well space is there
and we're going to climb it
and the moon and the planets are there
and new hopes for knowledge and peace
are there
and therefore as we set sail
we ask god's blessing
on the most hazardous and dangerous
and greatest adventure
on which man has ever embarked
thank you
[Applause]